Hello everybody!
Sorry.
I think, um, if I sound really sad, I think I have a reason
to be sad today.
Sorry, I'm sad, I'm sad laughing.
I'm trying not to cry because uh, I'm very emotional right
now.
I think this is why um, um, I really wanted to stream today
still because I know if I don't I'm just gonna cry but
talking to you guys always make me really happy cheers me up
and I know that I know that I'll stop crying when I if I get
to just hang out with my dragoons
thank you everybody I'm sorry it was super out of my control
um I was trying to find like a way to like have what's the
word uh compromise because I said I was willing to delay the
stream for like one and a half hours max um but i was told
uh i was told that uh uh it wasn't enough time um and that
for the best option it was to be pushed back to tomorrow
sorry i know i know i shouldn't I know it's just it's silly
it's silly it's a silly thing to cry about um but the team
did work really hard like um when tomorrow please don't
blame the project team uh a lot everybody that worked on it
they some of them had to do crunch hours and uh they
basically
i know like uh some of them basically really haven't slept
the last two days so um they were trying really hard to get
it done in time um and at that point like we we were like
everybody was just like it's it's just not possible um and
yeah i would have liked to be informed earlier because i was
open to pushing the date back a day or two uh but uh
everyone thought that it was possible so uh i wasn't
informed until uh the last i think like 10 minutes 10 to 15
minutes before the stream was about to start that it was
just at that point it wouldn't be ready in time um the
reason why i didn't want to push uh i didn't really want to
push it back too far is that, because like there was another
option, it was to basically delay the stream 3 to 4 hours or
like 2 to 4 hours and at that point I was like, it's just
better to push it to the, to tomorrow I was just like if the
delay is going to be like 2 to 4 hours at that point like um
we might as well just stream on sun like have the reveal on
sunday um and because like i know there's an overlap i'm not
gonna play dumb about it i i know there was gonna be an
overlap and I just I know people I don't want to force
people to make a decision and stuff and um because you know
both both events are incredibly hype and everything and um I
felt that like at that point if it's gonna be delayed to two
to four hours it was just it was just at that point i might
as well just push it to tomorrow so i had to make the
incredibly uh tough decision to just uh just have it for
tomorrow instead because i didn't want to rush it wasn't
just this project team a lot of um there's like other people
outside of the project team that also worked incredibly hard
uh to have it done by this deadline um and it wouldn't be
fair to their efforts if uh i had to rush that to rush my uh
new skin suit reveal um just because i didn't i was i didn't
want to overlap or anything uh because i know like there's
also like i know there's like debut fatigue and stuff like
that i i hope you You know, too tired of debut stuff,
re-debut debut stuff by tomorrow.
Um, and, um, uh, and I really do hope, like, uh, you guys,
uh, I know, I know it won't be as hyped.
If I, if I did the reveal today versus tomorrow, I know,
like, tomorrow, a lot of you guys did open up your schedule
for today.
that you might not be there for tomorrow and i'm really
really really do apologize um because you know you guys it's
not i guess i would want it to stream today as well because
i still wanted to you know because you guys uh gave up your
own schedule to like you know watch silly me watch silly me
and um yeah i still wanted to hang out with you guys wanted
to stream because you guys gave up your schedule to be there
for me
so i still hope you guys uh will still for those who won't
be able to be there tomorrow i still hope you will enjoy the
vine uh because everybody worked so hard for it
sorry i know a little trick for those who want to stop
crying if you don't have uh if you don't have a stream to
hang out with but a little trick is that I learned this from
volleyball.
I learned this from varsity volleyball because I was crying.
Because I got I was like, I got scolded by my coach for
being late for a game.
And I was crying because I was like I'm sorry.
I was late.
And then my coach was like, my coach Which was like drink
water so you'll stop crying and it works.
She was just like if you want to cry and you can't stop
crying.
If you're crying and you suddenly drink water you'll stop
And it works.
It does work.
I don't know how it does that but like I stopped crying
because I just suddenly drank water when I started to cry.
But yes, I had to, I get really emotional.
I think it's also because it's also like I'm really
emotional because I've been really stressed out.
I know my project team, I bet they've been, I know they've
been incredibly stressed out as well due to like how tight.
the deadline was um they had like around two and a half
months to really get all of this done and the scope of the
project and it was my first time there's a lot of these
people in like I said before for this project this has to be
the most the biggest and most expensive thing I've ever
funded and I've ever produced and worked with and there's a
lot of people uh there's a lot of incredibly hard for this
particular project and I know like they must have been like
super anxious they didn't want to tell me that there was
going to be a delay which I would understand which I of
course 100% understand because like you know I won't be
surprised if they thought that like you know they wanted to
push as much as they can to get it done by today which I
don't them um of course it is still sad that because i like
we've been hyping it for a week and everything and then just
to hit that uh uh snack but like i said this team was the
most i've ever employed to work on something like this so i
know i've never i've never had a delay that delayed this
much before when it came to like special events or special
projects that I work on like I try to make do with at least
like one to two hours and if like the product team is
watching this right now I'm sorry if I said some harsh words
on the survey on the Discord survey I don't know if I was
like really blunt or I don't know when I get really
emotional I can get like super blunt and I just I don't
fluff my words and I really apologize Because I do get like
really emotional to the point where I don't fluff my words
when I type.
You know like when you don't have...
When like when you're typing your word...
Like when you're typing in chat and stuff.
And like in chat and stuff.
And you don't know what the emotion behind it is when you're
typing words.
and stuff because you're not saying it you're not seeing it
and stuff and uh and yeah like texting you when you're
texting it and so like i wasn't like fluffing my words and
stuff i was like to a point like very blunt and i was like
uh please in the future please let me know like ahead of
time um like like i would have i understand like i would
have understood if so it's of us so i was like i would have
understand if you guys needed more time if there needed to
be a delay like maybe but you just needed to tell me earlier
you just need to tell me like maybe even like three hours
earlier or a day or two earlier like i would have understand
i would have pushed it back um because it's not fun to like
announce that it's been pushed back like 10 minutes before
starting it's it's not it's not fun at all
um uh and so like it's it's really understandable uh and
like if there was just you know everybody's like was really
stressed out and because they really really it's i hope you
guys would uh would love tomorrow what we're bringing
tomorrow because i know i know the hype won't be as hyped as
today because everybody would be was expecting it to be
today oh my god i need a fuck okay i need to tell my new
mama to not post
give me a sec i need to send a message
Because I gave a time.
I gave a time.
And I was like.
You can post it.
At this time.
I forgot.
Oh my god.
I have.
Sorry.
We are pushing the stream.
Oh my god.
That was so fucking anticlimactic.
At least you know.
This is why it's good that.
streamed because I would have forgotten to message my mama
to not post oh my god because I was like yeah you can post
it at this time because I think at that time um uh it is
like at this time that i should be done i should have my new
skin suit revealed and then they're like okay and now i'm
just like oh okay we appreciate the shade uh it was a huge
delay that we couldn't control just wanted to let you know
so you don't accidentally tweet it out oh my god oh please
don't sketch your old tweet that would have been so awkward
oh my god but yes we're we have to my me and my staff team
have to like uh oh no the the uh celia knows celia knows
that it like because they're in the server so they know that
it's been uh delayed um the mama did not know so i needed to
uh i needed to be like oh okay please yes like um oh i hope
it's not scheduled i really hope it's not scheduled i hope
it's not all right we'll find out in an hour we'll stay
until like an hour at least an hour to see like if if it and
then I'll just be like surprise I like surprise this was the
reveal this entire time okay what was I uh what what was i
gonna say before that um uh what but yes what was he saying
before i was like oh i need a message uh i need a message my
mama to not say anything to not accidentally post it uh
um or i messaged i messaged them on uh on discord um to not
i I don't know if they saw it yet, so I'm just gonna wait.
What were...
Okay.
What was I saying before then?
All right, let's all be filled with anxiety for an hour.
That's great.
I basically just gave my chat...
Now I gave my chat FOMO.
Because they're like, oh no, now I have to stay.
Just to see if it actually gets revealed.
Now you can't leave.
Because now you have FOMO.
Anyway, anyway, what was I saying before, guys?
No, we're not going to do a countdown.
That makes it worse.
That makes everything much worse.
I really appreciate, like, Mint messaged me about him, was
like, is everything okay?
And I was like, no.
I literally replied back.
I was like, no.
I'm crying.
uh but like uh like mint messaged me and did cheer me up and
um and uh but i just want if if anybody in the project team
is watching like i really apologize uh for how blunt my
words were like i wasn't being like guys for those who are
wondering i wasn't being like i was just like you know we're
all frustrated and i was just like uh we're all frustrated
and stuff we're all like stressed out um and i was just like
basically i just like kept it straight i was just like
please just next time as i like next time i know like you
know i'm not corporate i'm just an indie but like please i
next time i do appreciate if uh uh if like i was told like
if i knew like ahead of time and i know i know everybody is
so stressed out about it and um and i really direct my words
were for that uh and i do get really emotional um i actually
stepped back after that uh i invited because when that
project server um it was just i was i was basically
overseeing everything just myself like i didn't invite any
of my staff members there and um and um because of that um
from my experience i know when to step back uh like i need
like when i know like you know from all my previous
experiences now i know when i have to just step back because
i don't want to say something i regret in the future um so
like i said i told him straight i was just like i'm going to
take a step back and invite a staff member uh to the server
um and they're gonna handle all of this now they're gonna be
my messenger because I was like what I don't know what I'm
gonna I don't know what I was gonna say because I was so
emotional I didn't want them to feel bad I didn't because I
didn't want to like make them feel bad or like accidentally
guilt trip people so I was just like I need to be
professional and I'm going to put my staff member in the
server and um and like my staff member is gonna handle it
like just being the messenger now um and um and i'm gonna
leave the server uh i'll might i'll join back when i like
i'll join back after the realvia like when i've calmed down
when i feel a lot like after the real via so yeah i like
invited i told my staff member what's happening and then i
was like can you join the server and just like delegate
everything for and just like relay send me the files and
like relay stuff to me about everything if they need that
from me and uh so then i just like i like invited i just
invited my staff member and i gave them control the server
and i was like i'm out peace i'm out because i feel like i'm
gonna say something really really like something i might
like might be like unprofessional like i might get like
super emotional and i don't want to guilt trip them i don't
want to make them feel worse or anything because i can't
help it when i get like super emotional um and i i'm worried
that i might say something that might feel like guilt trippy
or something or like i didn't want to make them feel bad or
anything and like feel worse because if i feel this way i am
not i will not be surprised I feel this way, like, feeling
incredibly emotional.
They are also feeling equally, or if not more so, like,
terrible.
Or, like, terrible because they couldn't meet the deadline.
So that's why, like, that's why...
I knew that I had to take a step back.
Because, if anything, I know, like, that team.
some of them were pulling all nighters and stuff to make
sure it was done by the deadline and um like i knew that
like i had to take a step back because like you know i knew
like the things i did type in the server would must have
like hurt them a lot because like you know i was saying i i
said like i was just i was just sad you know like like i was
i gave put my feelings on my sleeve and being like it's like
they're like we're really sorry for the delay i was like
it's okay i understand I am crying but I do understand and
like stuff like that like you know if I read that I'd be
like shit I feel terrible because I made somebody cry
obviously I couldn't stop myself because like I'm like I'm
upset and like stuff like that and I was suddenly like I
wish I didn't type that I wish I uh I wish I didn't type
that that for them to see it I wish I kept that in um kept
that within myself because I know like obviously that made
them feel bad and when they see so you like that type of
message is for me because I'm like I guilt trip I guilt trip
them a little bit from that because I was just like I know I
can't stop myself I'm crying but I understand
and that's why like after that I was just like
I need to take a step back.
I am going to have my staff member handle all of that.
And so I can take a step back and just decompress and stuff.
But please, like I said, tomorrow.
Because obviously there's going to be credits and
everything.
Please, like, appreciate.
Like, when you see why it was delayed, you guys will
understand.
because it was a big project there were so many things going
into it um and you'll see why it was delayed um it was
there's there's just a lot going on it might not be a super
long stream when it comes to like what the content is in
itself but a lot of effort was put into it in general and um
and you guys will see why um and um i even said like i knew
like crunch time would be a factor and i even was like i'm
willing to hire as many people as i can to make sure there's
no like people don't actually sacrifice their health um
obviously we didn't predict how ambitious the project was in
the end it was incredibly ambitious and um even with the
amount of people I hired it was still not enough people
because some people had to do all-nighters and some people
was like they were they got sick in the middle of it and
then but then we couldn't really do much about it um and
yeah like even though we hired so many people and we still
had to had crunch hours and crunch hours as well as people
pulling all-nighters hard they worked really really really
hard um and i saw some of you mentioned they're like oh
that's like really like emotionally intelligent you to take
a step back um it's just because in the past i've learned
from my mistakes in the past because in the past i didn't
have like the opportunity to be like i know i'm gonna be
emotional so i'm gonna let someone else take over this while
i Like, I never had that opportunity before, but I knew
that's something I needed.
I knew that, like, if I do get emotional, I need somebody to
step in to, like, be the messenger for me.
And I need to take a step back.
So it's more so, like, I learned from my past experiences.
Because in my past, it was just me.
If I get emotional, I get emotional.
uh now i have the opportunity to send someone in to like uh
to basically you know be able to uh be my middleman and be
my messenger and when i do feel like i need to take a step
back and so yeah i really appreciate everybody for um
showing up though today because i know a lot people were
really expecting and we're like i'm so hey and i hope you
guys can uh still have that hype going in to tomorrow um and
that when the project does come out tomorrow that you guys
will give lots of love to the people working on it and um
and understand why it uh it got pushed back i mean i can
obviously explain more in detail tomorrow because i don't
want to leak what the stuff is and like why i feel a lot
better now talking to you guys that i'm not sad no i'm sad i
mean i can't be like now i'm not sad anymore like no because
that would be like being like a psychopath if i just
suddenly stop being sad but like you know i
And, uh, uh, I, I, I feel a lot better.
I do feel a lot better.
Like, I don't feel tears anymore.
Uh, I don't, uh, I don't feel, uh, I don't feel, uh, tears
anymore so yeah i i really i really appreciate just being
able to talk to you guys um um and yeah that's what i'm
saying like please please like uh send lots of love to the
project team especially when you get when it's revealed
who's being what who like like who was working on and um
because i i didn't know that people were pulling all
nighters and the crunch time like people were doing crunch
time because um i wasn't um i was just like overseeing the
general thing so i wasn't aware that the team were pulling
all nighters until today and uh because there's a lot of
messages because i have so many things going on behind the
scenes not just from this project team and uh um and i was
like and i have other things and so like sometimes i don't
read like all the messages that are going in on that server
so i wasn't aware that um some of the members were pulling
all nighters and stuff to make the deadline and that uh
people were like people were getting like uh crunching
crunching for it uh because i was very open i was like i'm
willing to hire as many people as possible um to make sure
to avoid that um and uh
um and it i uh so that's why i want to send like extra i
want you guys to send extra love uh to the team um for
tomorrow um Because, you know, they worked so hard on this.
And that's why I also decided I made the executive decision
to push it to tomorrow.
And it's just better for everybody.
Because I don't want it to, you know, if I push the stream
two to three hours.
And then when it's...
And we didn't even get a chance to, like, look through
whatever the project was.
like corrected in time and stuff for tomorrow um and
everything so yeah that's really what i really want to say i
don't again like i said i apologize uh and you can't i think
this is like the first time i've ever had something delayed
this late i guess like i had i uh um i think it's like the
first time i've ever had to delay something for something
like this late before uh because usually i just roll with it
but the whole reveal centers around this so i so like
usually i just roll of it and be like that's okay like maybe
um we'll just keep going we'll keep we'll keep streaming and
then like when it's ready i'll just pluck it in like plop in
but the whole thing really relied on that i was just like
all right tomorrow oh there's nothing that we can do
tomorrow it is for those wondering i will not be streaming
the srenova tournament for day two um and uh i saw I've had
delays before but I didn't realize with the scope of this
project it is incredibly ambitious it is incredibly
ambitious and it is in scope but I like I said I've have
never paid this much amount of money to to do the thing that
I wanted to do I I created there were so many things created
for it that uh was just like what time use like never to be
used again except for this specific thing it was incredibly
ambitious the scope was it was huge I had at least 20 people
hired for this project guys it was at least I think it was
at least 20 people that were working, um, if not more, I
see, I'm pretty, there was a lot, I remember scrolling
through the, the, like, list of people, and there was a lot
of people,
at least 20 plus, that means there could be, I've been more,
and you're not, fuck, I'm gonna count it, I have the credits
list, so I can count the credits, I'm like, try, okay, also,
like, I'm, like, really nervous, because I actually do have,
like, all the stuff set up on OBS, so, like, I'm trying to
make sure I don't accidentally click on anything other than
the chatting screen.
I'm trying to be...
All right, let's see.
One, two, three, four.
Oh, wait.
Five, six, seven, eight, nine.
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16.
17, 18, 19, 20, 21.
22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33, 34, 35, 36,
37.
I have 30, almost...
I have 37 people employed on this.
That was a lot more than 20.
Um...
Um, so, yeah.
Z, 4, 6, 8, 10, 12, 14, 16, 18, at 20, at 22, 24.
So, I, I, yeah, this project that I'm doing was, was very
ambitious.
um
uh and um and yeah i it's not thing is like i'm worried i'm
hyping it way too much that's and then when you guys see it
you're like oh that's what i hope i hope when you see it you
don't go like oh because i'm worried now that i said that
i'm hyping it way too much and you'll be like wow that i
can't believe you need 37 employees for that not employees
sorry contract i guess you can say contractors uh you need
contractors so um all right so go in just just pretend you
didn't hear how many people hired and just go in with like
low expectations chat just I go in um uh uh uh but yeah uh
anyway uh what else was I what else was I gonna say um I
don't remember what my topic was uh uh what my topic was
like uh before i oh yeah yeah i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
stream shenova i'm not gonna stream shenova tomorrow i'll
show up for shenova uh you know and i might have to leave
before the tournament is over so i need to tell rpr to get a
sub uh just in case because you know i told like they
apparently have it's apparently like later now the um i
don't know i need to look at what time the tournament is and
um and i need to tell you the i need to tell rpr that there
is a chance that if we do make it far which i doubt i i
think we're going to get eliminated in the second in the
first game We might get eliminated in the first or second
game.
But if we do make it further than what I expected, I will
drop out at 4 p.m.
I will 100.
No, actually, because I already have everything set up, I
literally just need the project file.
I need the project file and then I'm good to go.
But I will leave at exactly 4.30.
Like, I don't fucking care.
I will leave at 4.30.
This is much more important.
I, like, 5K would only pay for one thing.
I mean, maybe not one thing.
Maybe, like, two to three things from the project.
Like, I do not care.
Sorry, JK, I was exaggerating on that.
Two of the three things, maybe.
I don't even get 5K, because it's split between five of us.
Bro, I don't, like, 1K?
I don't even know, I don't even know, like, how much the
prize pool really is.
Like, I don't even know the prize pool on it.
So I don't know.
um how many how much money did you spend on this i will
reveal the amount after the reveal after the uh after the
reveal i will i will reveal it
oh oh hey there's no organizer yeah yeah i i don't know how
i think we're gonna get or something because you guys have
actual Valorant players and our PR thought that the game was
Overwatch uh was mostly Overwatch so he recruited zero
Valorant players um
um no don't tell us the cost okay what if I just keep in the
members only and they make everybody else have FOMO
you know what yeah that's how it's gonna pay i'm gonna
that's how i'm gonna pay it off i'm gonna reveal how much
the like the general estimate of how much i spent um in a
member stream so you got if you really want to know how much
it's it cost me i will reveal it in the member stream
I need to make back the amount that I uh spent and yeah I'm
gonna that's how that's how they get you that's how they get
you I feel a lot better uh I honestly feel so much better
just talking like I said I really do feel like whenever I do
get sad um I um I love uh talking to you guys because it
really does because if i done stream i would have cried so
much and i would have been like filled with like i guess
like you know i would kept everything inside and i would
have kept everything inside and i would have been like super
uh i would i would just not been healthy so i am glad even
though i can't really say like obviously say it a lot of
like the details of everything i'm really happy that i was
able to you know let out some of my frustrations to you guys
because oh my god i was so sad uh my friends were messaging
me was like are you guys okay i was like no i'm crying i'm
so sad because anybody would be sad in that scenario you
know i it was a lot of work um i hope uh but i really do uh
uh dark bled as a member i don't want to know how much Dark
Blade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, thank you for all the gifted chips, bye.
Thank you for the gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for joining the tomato farm.
I really appreciate it.
Don't worry, Dark Blade.
I'll say it in the member stream.
So, like, I'll give, like, a warning, like, trigger warning.
Trigger warning.
Uh, I will reveal the amount of money I spent.
Skip to X like pause
Look away
Warning the budget Thank you for all I give the chips Thank
you, thank you Trigger warning Financial irresponsibility
making poor financial decisions trigger warning
don't worry i will give you guys a warning in the members
for those who are like uh please i don't want to i don't
want to know No, no I'm not in the poor area.
No!
Oh, what else do I want to talk about?
I'm really excited, though, for my birthday.
For those who don't know, one of my five birthdays, God,
sometimes I don't even remember the fucking shit I write
sometimes.
But my real birthday, the very real birthday is July 4th.
And I'm super excited.
I'm really, really excited for July 4th.
Because there's like a lot of fun things.
Are happening in July.
It's crazy.
An entire country is celebrating my birthday.
Because I showed up first.
I showed up first Anyway But yes July 4th is going to be a
very very special day Not just July 4th But like the General
month of July There's like a lot of things There's like a
lot A lot a lot a lot of stuff Coming up in July That's been
in the works For a while Some of these things might be
announced tomorrow.
And it might be announced tomorrow.
But there's, like, multiple stuff going on that I'm really
excited for you guys to hear about.
And it's a lot.
It's...
Being in India is so hard.
me being indie is so hard guys oh my god thank you I know a
lot of people guys Akasupa thank you guys so much I really
appreciate it Amelia thank you for the Akasupa I'm sorry if
I haven't thank the other Akasupas yet I think like when you
guys were super chatting I was having a really deep
conversation but I will thank you guys I trust you to
deliver something amazing like you always did.
It'll be okay.
Don't let someone like this stop you.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I really, I really, really, really appreciate.
I think it's also because, like, I really, really appreciate
everybody for showing up.
And I really apologize if, like, you know, tomorrow for some
people it would be Monday.
They have to go to work.
And for some, they, like, cleared up their schedule today.
So they might not have a cleared schedule for tomorrow.
But no matter what, I really appreciate you guys.
supporting me and for showing up if you do show up and just
enjoying the ride um and everything because being indeed is
so difficult oh my god it is so much work marino thank you
for the akasupa thank you thank you remember even you're
disappointed for today's welcome for you and not the skin so
thank you thank you thank you thank you i really really
appreciate it guys like i said tomorrow when the project
team revealed itself i want you guys to give them lots and
lots of love um because they did work incredibly hard uh to
make this a reality so uh i really really really want you
guys to give them lots of love and support um because i know
if i feel terrible like uh they must be feeling like equally
not just as bad um and they deserve a lot of love too and um
uh and What else?
What else did I want to talk about?
I don't...
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, next week!
Next week?
Oh, my gosh.
Super hype.
But next week, Hiro invited me to try a PAL world early
access.
She got invited to do an early access PAL world, like two
days before.
Two days before...
the release date of the update.
So like I'll be checking out like she has a server for it
and everything and I'll be checking it out next week.
Yeah!
We're gonna have early access to the new update of Palworld.
That's really all I have planned for next week to be fair.
And also we finish Sandland.
And we fucking finally finish Sandland so we can play
another.
So we can finally start a new series um yeah um and oh my
gosh what else what else I don't actually know I'm trying to
think about like I wrote down some stuff I want to talk
about but a lot of these things I want to talk about is
usually like uh but it's like it's basically it's like uh
stuff regarding the new skin suit so i'm like it's sick i
need to do so it's like oh man all these things i signed up
for like i i wrote down it's for the new skin suit so like i
can't talk about that yet
um let's see let's see uh oh my god okay i was so surprised
okay i really want to tell you as this because I was like
really happy when I found out so um apparently because like
one of my friends messaged me this one of my uh one of my
friends messaged me this and uh they were like uh they were
um they were like oh my gosh hey uh I was so surprised it
made me feel so happy but they were telling because like
they were telling me like do you want an extra copy of like
Elden Ring and like the DLC do you want like a free copy of
it and I was like yeah I like free stuff I didn't buy it yet
and I have to play Elden Ring anyway um for like charity and
then like so then uh apparently my friend was like telling
me that the manager that he works with like she's apparently
a big fan of me and she was like she like like they were she
like gave like asked him if like i wanted a free copy of
elder ring and the dlc and i want to like uh play the dlc
during like the release and i was like i'm way too busy i
was like i'm sorry i'm i cannot play on release date i have
a million million different things going uh around and but
they're like no it's fine And then they're like, oh, we
still want to send you the collector's edition.
Oh, yeah, they wanted to ship me the DLC collector's edition
of the Elden Ring stuff.
And so I was like, yeah, sure.
I love free stuff.
So yeah, I was like super surprised.
about it like I like they they he told me about it like uh a
couple of days ago I think like like the last week or
something before and that I was like I don't know I was so
happy to find out that um like people working at Bandai are
like fans of me and I was like me I actually found a lot of
like devs and like a lot of devs and like um people who work
at like uh uh oh my gosh okay I can't guys which sponsor it
was but it was for like it was it's related to gaming and
basically like um they requested like they're like oh we
have somebody here at the company that is like a big fan of
you like can we have can we send this thing to you and can
you sign it uh can you autograph it and then like send it
back to us and then um i was like yeah of course i was so
surprised i was so it's not hyatt i'll just say because like
i i know i know like hyatt like i hi it was also like um a
uh like a big fan too and i really appreciate the support
they give me but there was a different sponsor it's not
hasn't been revealed yet the sponsor hasn't been revealed
yet by the way um so that's what if you're like oh it's hot
it's not
but i it was just it was just so sweet it was really really
sweet and they were just like oh can we like send this to
you and like like because they were sending me other stuff
regarding like the sponsorship so they're like can we like
send this to you and like like because like one of our
workers is like a huge fan of you and like could you like
autograph it and then like uh send it back to us i was like
oh yes of course of course like uh i remember like um uh one
of our staff members was like like was gonna be like you
could say they told me about it and then they're like you
could say these things the first one was like normally you'd
be like the first one was like oh she normally doesn't
autograph these things like it has to be paid you know like
meet and greets and stuff or like store items or the second
option would be like yes we'll make an exception and i was
like no make an exception like i thought it was really sweet
like i don't want them to like i don't want them to be like
uh like reject that i just I thought it was incredibly
sweet.
Uh...
I mean, they're giving me money anyway.
Like...
They're...
They're giving me money anyway for the...
For, like, for the sponsors.
So, like, I don't really care.
Uh...
Sorry, thank you for the a super thank you thank you
sometimes things won't go in the way we want it so we must
blame Canada yeah fucking Canada I love how my skin suit is
I mean obviously it's like y'all cowboy themed and I am
Canadian I had to I had to like research like I had to like
research like like western the
The Canadian cowboys.
Yes, but I'm not from the East Coast.
So I didn't know anything about, like, actual...
I remember I was, like, researching.
Because, like, the Aditya.
The Bounty Hounder Cowboy stuff was given by...
uh was given by my my new mama and it was like you know i
thought it was a very creative idea and when you see it
you'll understand i thought it was pretty creative um
because like i wanted something more i guess like you know
pew pew pew pew but i hate tech work
Like VTuber designs that are like based off of like, you
know, pew pew pew pew, but it's techware.
It's always techware.
I am tired.
I don't like techware.
I'm sorry.
So I was like, y'all.
And then my mama was like, I don't know how to.
My mama was like, it's mostly techware, but we could make
it.
cowboy and I was like oh my god that is so smart that is so
clever um I just think techware is like um very like it's
like a bit overdone now I won't say very overdone but I feel
like techware like vtuber designs has been like pretty sort
of overdone now and like it follows the same trope like the
jacket thing so like i feel like and i don't want to follow
the status quo i didn't want to follow the status quo of
like uh uh you know you know what i'm talking about the tech
wear jacket you know exactly what i'm talking about when i
say tech wear jacket yes but it's like it's always it always
shows up
I'm tired of that jacket.
I'm tired of seeing that jacket.
Yeah, the Arc...
Yes, the Arc Knight's jacket.
Yes, that's so true.
The Arc Knight jacket.
Yeah, that's why I was like, I don't want...
I was like, y'all time.
It's cowboy time.
It's time for the cowboy.
boy because i want a pew pew pew pew pew pew i want i want a
pew pew pew pew pew pew pew but not be tech weird um anyway
uh but what else what else uh did i want to uh what else did
i want to talk Oh, someone asked me any news on the
Gamersups Cup.
We, it was a lot.
We received more than a thousand entries.
I feel really bad for my assistant because I was like, our
staff team was like, assistant, my personal assistant.
You will go through the process of like filtering out what
was eligible uh until we were at um what was it 300 i'm
sorry i haven't looked through i looked at it like twice
because even i was getting overwhelmed after it got filtered
uh after the submissions uh got filtered but it took a while
um they went from a thousand plus submissions to like I
think 300 I need to check it again um but um and it took
like a couple of weeks to really I think it took like two to
three weeks to fully like uh go through all the submissions
to see like which one like which one will be approved for me
to look all the the final list of submissions that i'll be
looking at to choose top 20 and they're all so fucking good
it's so it i'm it's so difficult to pick there's i have to
pick 20 submissions and like even like the the filtered list
it is incredibly difficult to pick i looked at it like once
or was like I'm gonna save this for another day my focus is
gonna be on something else now there's also the thing about
how hard it is to be an indie because it's like oh my god oh
there's so many decisions I have to make now
I was like will you ever will you ever be corporate again
Only if I get a really good offer
Like because it's like It's like I get to keep Okay not all
I get to keep like a hundred percent Like of my profits And
the thing is though Like It's like a thing is like Yeah it's
a lot harder That's a lot harder uh it's a lot harder to to
be an indie because there's so many more decisions but like
why join a company when i when like i a lot of stuff that
like um that i'm doing already i'll still be doing
like like i feel like the biggest benefit for me is just the
fact so like that's what i'm saying if the offer is like
really really fucking good like i i don't know like yeah um
and um what oh my gosh what what do i want to say and it's
just it's just like it like the only thing that was like i'm
like thinking like oh like what it can offer me is like the
fact that you know um you have a group to be with type deal
like setting up collabs is one of the hardest things about
being into indie because you know you have to it's easier to
just be like at everybody who wants to play.
But as an indie you can't add everybody you have to actually
hit up people and reach out it's like I really want to play
this game or you like down for it and stuff like that.
And so there's not really like an established group that you
like establish like set of people that you can just like be
in at everybody and just be like, let's play this game.
Who wants to join in?
And that's like, I think like one of my biggest like, oh,
like thing that is just, it's like one of the most difficult
things as an indie.
And obviously like, like I said, I didn't want to overlap.
Because I knew, like, you know, I'm just me.
I'm not going to do some fucking David versus Goliath shit
there.
Like, I don't...
I'm not up for that.
I'm just me.
I'm not doing some David versus Goliath.
Um, and, uh, obviously, like, I know, like, I was like, ah,
I'm choking, I don't.
David, this is alternate universe, David versus Goliath.
Alternate universe.
What if David lost?
You cannot say David's gun, David won when you, oh no, damn
well.
You know, you know, damn well, we're all coping with you say
that.
You see?
Anyway,
yeah, I feel so much better.
though i really feel so much better um and i do hope for
those who were curious who've never uh who've never like uh
were like just showing up for the first time just to watch
the skin suit reveal that you guys will show up for tomorrow
if not it's okay i'll just keep moving forward there's still
so much good news uh going forward and i know like it was
like a opportunity that I wasn't able to debut a new skin
suit today but shit happens it was a learning lesson for all
of us and everybody involved it was a huge learning lesson
for everybody I didn't even I was so nervous I didn't even
eat anything today I didn't even eat lunch or dinner because
I was just um i was just incredibly nervous um i'm not even
hungry that's the thing i wasn't even hungry because i was
just you know it's just you know i was so i was feeling of
anxiety about other this and uh yes i will eat i promise uh
i will promise i will uh i will eat uh um after after the
stream um but i really appreciate everybody for uh showing
up today um and i apologize to people in asia who might have
to go to work or go to school tomorrow because it will be
monday for you guys and i really apologize that we weren't
able to get it today but um if you are going to watch the
vod i hope you do enjoy the experience and enjoy the new
look hey guys i'm gonna call it
Everybody, I know it's gonna be like almost to you up to
like seven and we still have like five more minutes, but
like I'm scared
I'll deal with it off stream if they didn't get the message
Anyway, anyway, I'll see you guys I'll see you guys tomorrow
I'll see you guys tomorrow as always everybody stay hydrated
pasta check it up and move around to get that blood flowing
you stay up from me head to bed because you guys you guys
deserve it you guys really deserve it especially if you're
staying up this late for me for those who are like from enue
and I know I know it's super early in enue right now so
thank you guys and I really apologize I'll try definitely
learning lesson from me and I'm gonna work harder to keep up
with the and like the projects and dates and stuff and
everything um but yes i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye i need like okay i need like remember i need to
make sure i don't accidentally i'm gonna put it on oh my
gosh is this the right screen oh we're gonna find out we're
gonna find out if this is the right screen i'll see you guys
soon guys bye This is the right screen.
We're going to find out now.